Hello!
Yeah, yeah. Hello.
Hello.
Who is this?
It's me.
Me who?
Me, me.
Want to have a better recall rate?
A new study carried out by an associate professor at Montclair State University...
...has found out by simply clenching your fist,...
...memories and small details can be more easily recalled.
Researchers asked more than 50 right-handed study participants...
...to memorize 72 different words.
They were assigned at random into varying hand clenching groups...
...and then there was one group that did nothing.
The researchers found that participants had better memory....
...while clenching the right hand for memorizing...
...and balling up the other hand while attempting to recall certain facts.
The lead author states, "I would say that it would be worth trying."
"Take parking your car in the parking lot."
"As you park you can clench your right hand and when you're trying to find it,"...
...clench your left hand."
In another experiment, researchers from the University of Northumbria,...
...found that the scent of rosemary might actually improve memory function.
Research subjects performed better in a room that had a rosemary scent in it...
...than rooms with no scent.